[Music]
we make a great team
[Music]
hello hey hi um
not a big deal just wondering when your
kids were small did you ever i don't
know uh smack their heads into a wall
usually we just gave time-outs no no
accidentally um
we just kind of bonked lily's head and
she really wasn't very hard and she's
not acting any differently but i just
worried it happens luke used to bang his
head all the time and he's fine okay all
right thank you thanks it helps okay
okay we gotta take her to the doctor
load up the car
what the hell were you thinking
i'll answer that for you you weren't
thinking
you think that's funny popeye no
popeye
i should be fishing but i'm hauling my
ass across town trying to save you two
from a little dog
at least we gotta have a dog for a few
minutes there we go
you could show a little gratitude you
know these pants are new
climbing over that fence i might erect
them
that's mature
i'm sorry we're sorry we're sorry sorry
you said rectum
i'm sorry dad and we're so glad that you
came thank you got us i was very smart
the way that you
distracted the dog 12 times a year i get
sausages that's it
the hell am i going to do till june i
want to grab a picture of you and claire
i want to post it on my inseam account
uh what's inseam i use it for home
tailoring claire yeah could you get in
here please my two superstars okay
i can't believe you're one with that bad
knee
well at least if somebody tries to steal
that thing they got to get through this
guy i just did what any hero would do
are you wearing makeup uh well yeah i
got a bruise i thought i thought you
screamed and he ran away uh well there
was uh there was a scuffle you went with
your instinct
fight or flight you fought i'm gonna
post this on inseam double click
damn it
you fought
you fought uh how close you get to this
intruder okay claire that is just about
enough mitchell suffered a trauma and i
don't appreciate your mocking tone
excuse us okay
thank you sweetie okay look we both know
two things for certain i look fabulous
and coral and you didn't fight off any
intruder
i like michael i really do i just i
don't want her to get her heart broken
when it comes to boys her self-esteem is
low enough as it is i don't know alex
seems pretty darn tough oh she's just
sarcastic on the outside inside she's
just a fragile little girl this by all
means look right at me when you say that
if she wants to get her heart broken by
a gay guy she can do so when she's 18 or
19 and can drink her way through it oh
you're a good mother i don't know claire
you could be wrong boys aren't as
concerned about traditional masculinity
anymore you know they're not butching it
up they're not pushing down their
feelings yeah they care about their
clothes they they they groom everybody's
hairless yeah you can't tell anything
anymore
hey hey uncle mitch uncle cam this is
michael hi hello hi
okay come on
yep he's gay we stand corrected yeah
claire in case you want to add something
i put the box of dresses outside and
this is the book of sneakers knackers
thanks
michelle we did have something to add to
this box of um snickersnackers
why
english is not her first language and
she's just trying to help mitchell come
on you can't do that you can't just
change the rules this is what we do when
gloria says something silly we
innocently laugh behind her back come on
she's had a rough week all right she's
really worried about tia maria cecilia
and that surgery oh and then she lost
herself on a pilates how do you know
this we have coffee oh have so when did
this become like a thing
what's the big deal we're friends i like
gloria
that's no big deal
i have nothing against her i just think
all right so before you get all judgy i
gave her that vase
after i gave it to you
and there you go that is me clearly
running in front of bridges oh yeah yeah
with the reagan bush poster in the
window huh the photo is a fake
it's not my fault manny made it manny
was photoshopping everything
so joe was in real danger i did not
realize how easy it would be for you to
connect those dots pretty disappointing
to you luke well you know it's easy to
see where he learned it from his
mother's a cheater
what oh don't get so hot and bothered
your makeup's already running and what
do you mean chinese character on your
bruise yeah it's probably an imprint
from the intruder's ring he's i'm sure
he was in a gang of some sort just give
it up mitchell he knocked himself out
with some nunchucks that i confiscated
as acting vice principal oh my god kung
sue is back daddy did you hear that
hello
oh thank god
had so many cups of tea that gave me my
own one of these oh there you go so
congratulations on the whole marriage
thing how amazing is that right yeah
we're gonna hear some big gay wedding
bells soon well just wedding bells
yeah yeah of course we've always talked
about it but you know it's just a matter
of finding the right timing and then
there's a couple of other factors uh tax
supplications and estate planning stop
i'm swimming i'm just being practical
you're the same way
you told phil to take back your
engagement ring and buy you a washer
dryer well don't put this back on me
come on what is cam's biggest complaint
about you you're not romantic this is
your opportunity mitchell you should go
home tonight and surprise him with a big
splashy proposal
he would really like it if i proposed to
him mm-hmm
i guess i could stop after work and pick
up a card oh my god you're hopeless no
mitchell okay this is what you do okay
it really should be your own idea though
no come on come on i need help please
fine okay
tonight you cook him his favorite meal
you opened the best bottle of wine and
just as the two of you were sitting down
to enjoy it you break up with him what
why because then as he's at his lowest
you pack the question he goes from agony
to ecstasy it's so romantic
you're kidding right more traditional
right
you look into his eyes and you say
i saw a doctor
he found a small dark mask what are you
and then just as he begins to cry you
pull out a black box with the ring in it
there's your small dark mass it's genius
you're a disaster you can go to the
disaster route too did you ever hear how
i told phil we were gonna have luke i
said thousands of children die every day
so i finally get out of the closet and
there's dad looking down at me been
there
this reminds me of the time i walked in
on you watching top gun you need to stop
telling that story claire mitchell still
resents you for quitting the figure
skating team when you were kids ladies
come inside with me please work it out
come on
thanks cam is he serious is that what
your little jab was about this morning
no yes okay yes yes i guess i'm just a
little angry but you know
you stole my moment claire yeah 21 years
ago no but it doesn't matter to you
because you had your own moments you had
cheerleading and high school plays and
uh making out with the quarterback oh
come on you made out with him too yeah
but we had to keep it a secret
you shouldn't have quit it was selfish
you want to know why i quit i quit to
protect you
from what glory
fame now come on i was bigger than you i
was bigger than you and i was afraid you
wouldn't be able to lift me you you were
dropping me in practice and i didn't
want you to humiliate yourself in front
of all of those people you dropped me
all the time
come on
could you just forgive me and
move on
of course yes yes yes i'm sorry i'm
sorry
ah
this must seem so pettier huh well it's
a little silly but we all have our thing
don't we just glad you're getting it
out of you
are you trying to lift me you are you're
trying to lift me
that's it mitchell
[Music]
you